this is terrible you don't know what
you're doing Adam Sandler yeah that's
right
I collect antiquities I'm a serious
person I'm writing a movie right now
about the Russian Revolution oh really
who does Kevin James play in it aha it's
a serious movie Trotsky ah there it is
but he's got a wife who never wears a
bra I think you're gonna like it thanks
for dressing up by the way all right
back to this plate I think you could use
it for a variety of things new item up
there how much you guys want to pay for
me to stick my socks in this morons
mouth I will did football legend Joe
Theismann just bid $1,000 to put a sock
in my mouth
you bet okay but let's get it going a
little seriously back to the porno
please box talking about okay even
better
1,300 Joe Theismann so the Joey
Theismann congratulations for getting a
sock in your mouth 1,300 bucks Joe
Theismann can I stick the sock in his
mouth I'll pay extra yes you may because
I just sold my item to the man in the
gray shirt at table 18 and YPD you're
under arrest
[Music]
my leg
you broke my other leg oh this was
supposed to be a safe event nothing to
see here except for the bone Oh sticking
out of the leg my PT
I need a commandeer this vehicle it's a
crossover it's a crossover SUV and you
can't have it I'm a cop can you please
get out of the car no this is Schmidt's
mom's car and I'm more scared of her
than I am of some two-bit thug I'm not a
thug I'm police okay the name one law
don't kill people that's on me I set the
bar too low look please just get out
okay you can't drive I'm not getting out
right also I have the seat one Ron I
don't just have a really hot but doesn't
matter to me a purpose getting away oh
it's very hot
thanks a lot
New York you know what if your set is so
great then how come it's not state
capital but who cares about the state's
capital this is the concrete jungle
where dreams are made Oh doesn't sound
right where dreams are made up
I don't know you tell me it's your dumb
city it's grammatically hot whatever I'm
sure wherever you're from has strange
song during about it to Los Angeles damn
and all the songs they are so good
I'm chasing a criminal your soup is not
important you took an oath to serve and
protect that applies to my suit you know
that's not what the office about you're
making a point you don't even believe
oh damn it got away well I saw my soup
you tell me which is worse my thing very
clearly my thing what's going on
any idea our martial house called this
special meeting I don't know do you
think she saw the video we put on the
internet to lure Jimmy Figgis down here
corndog pinned by go-cart its pwned but
that was really adorable well she has it
would ruin our entire plan there she
goes
gentlemen so so how's it going it's good
it's really good
keep it a little proof no contact with
Brooklyn no one's questioned our
identities definitely staying off the
net hey Craig right that's it that's all
you have to say to me yeah I think we're
good so nobody's gonna ask me how I'm
doing
oh I didn't think this was a personal
conversation it's not turned back around
watch a movie this is official business
I was just testing you because Greg is
the kind of person who cares about his
friends and can sense when something is
off with him is something off with you
Marshall house I don't know what I mean
I met someone
okay and um I mean it's not my husband I
mean nothing's happened yet but my
entire body is on fire he's Cuban is
this still official business of course
it is shut up and watch the movie yeah
pop quiz if Larry were married and
everything was fine and I mean honestly
everything is totally fine sure but he
knew that one night with this person
could give him everything he needed for
the rest of his life
why'd he do it yes yes good what if this
person that Larry met was young I mean
really young well I don't think Larry
would do anything illegal you know it
seems to me Larry has needs and deserves
to have those needs met
Gregg you're really great at being
undercover no you both pass the test
let go let me not
please don't slam the door again we have
a bit of a medical situation I wish I
could help but unfortunately I have a
bit of a wooden duck situation yeah
excuse me right now still all about the
duck Frederick years ago when we moved
in together and antique duck decoy of
his wasn't it placed it wasn't misplaced
you threw it in the trash and with it
our relationship no please we had other
problems or have you forgotten about
Dave Dave and I were coworkers and
nothing more nothing more right problem
solved everybody's friends let's go help
Sharon I will be happy to assist you if
you will just admit Raymond that you
threw my decoy in the garbage that will
never happen because it's not true thank
you for nothing good day
hi would you mind just standing there
with your glorious beard for one moment
I'll be right back what the hell just
tell what he wants to hear but it's a
long I don't give a crap sir
Sharon needs a doctor so get over
yourself I'm telling you threw away his
stupid duck and give him 20 bucks to buy
a new one it calls seven hundred and
forty dollars what that is an insane
price for a duck that's way too much all
right now I'm angry about the wrong
thing look just fix this for Sharon
Frederick the duck was ugly and gross
and I threw it in the garbage Wow well I
know what I'm thankful for this
Thanksgiving the truth hello I'm your
new commanding officer captain seth
dozerman my motto is simple efficiency
efficiency efficiency can probably just
say it once are you making fun of my
stutter Oh tricked you I don't have a
stutter boom
I've already stablished my authority
through my amazing sense of humor well
done sir welcome to the nine-nine
I'm Sergeant Terry Jeffords and I'm not
interested I have no use for people I
find people weird and confusing I live
my life by numbers you see this watch it
tells me how many calories I burn at any
time question how many calories do you
think I burned walking from there to
there you female closest to me oh uh
three three try 0.8 numbnuts I made
promises to my superiors that I most
certainly cannot keep that's why I need
you idiots to work twice as hard no no
strike that four times as hard no no
strike that
I need you morons to work eight times
harder than you've ever worked and your
entire life I'm having a heart attack
yeah I'm having a heart attack
get back to work please hello my name
can you spell that please M and he be
okay sickly
yes the clay is silent all right got it
you seen this man before you shot last
night oh thank you no sir that's ours he
kept it
Rawdon Fire Marshal Boone just called he
told me you should check your drawer
Wow look at that I've been boond well
the joke's on him because I was out of
shaving cream I see we are once again at
war with a fire department you are not
to retaliate oh I wouldn't dream of it
sir
in fact I'm gonna send over a little
peace offering some of Sal's famous
sauce hello
hey you're Bianca right mm-hmm I'm Jake
I'm a friend of Freddy's from work I'm
looking for him well which Jake are you
are you jakey lady hands are you jakey
the Jew well it feels weird saying this
but I hope jakey the Jew mm-hmm Jake
Peralta
Freddie actually said I should come by
here if I was ever in trouble oh oh okay
well Freddie was here but he left
becoming Clennon crappy address
somewhere hold on so did he say where he
was heading or heard about chief Peralta
I know you were the rat get him up get
your hands up lady hands we may die
today
you know actually heard about a guy who
died while eating hot wings yeah he was
terminally ill beforehand Oh unrelated I
always thought I'd die at the hands of
my own clone well that's why you have to
brand the number two into your clones
cheek you shouldn't have a clone if you
don't know that all right you ready here
we go that's nothing Amateur Night
I can't believe us had three peppers
next to it on the menu Oh
you